تبارك اكثر من مليون شخص يوم الخميس في
فرنسا احتجاجا على مشروع قانون برفع سن
التقاعد بالتزامن مع سلسله اضرابات ان شاء
الله قطاعات حيويه في البلاد وتاتي هذه
الاحتجاجات وفي سياق توتر اجتماعيا يضرب
دول اوروبيه بينها الى جانب فرنسا
بريطانيا والبرتغال التاني شهدت خلال
الفتره الماضيه احتجاجات واضرابات عماليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ان كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الاسباب التي
قادت الى الاضطرابات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه التي تشهدها هذه الدول وما
حجم مساهمه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في
خلقه هذه الاضطرابات
وما متى قدره الحكومات الاوروبيه التي
تعاني هذه الازمات على الصمود وما الحلول
التي يمكن ان تلجا اليها لمعالجه ازماتها
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نقرا تجاه هذه الدول
لزياده انفاقها العسكري في هذا التوقيت
وكيف ستنعكس ازماتها الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه على موقفها من حرب اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
عشيه اعلانه رفع ميزانيه بلاده العسكريه
بنسبه للثلث على مدى سبع سنوات
لتصل الى ما قيمته 400 مليار
رئيس الفرنسي يوم الخميس
معتبره مراقبون
حقيقيا بتظاهر نحو مليون ومئه الف شخص في
باريس وفي مدن فرنسيه وذلك احتجاجا على
قانون قانون يرفع سن التقاعد في البلاد
مع اضراب شل قطاعات النقل والصحه والتعليم
بينما اتفقت النقابات الكبرى في فرنسا عقب
المظاهرات على تنظيم يوم تعبئه جديده
نهايه هذا الشهر وذلك مواصله لسلسله
الاحتجاجات النقابيه التي شهدتها فرنسا
خلال الفتره الماضيه
وفي بريطانيا التي شهدت خلال الفتره
الماضيه ايضا اضطرابات واضرابات واحتجاجات
للمطالبه بتحسين الاجور نفذ قطع التمريض
نفذ قطع التمريض يومي الاربعاء والخميس
الماضيين
مدته يومانا بعد اضراب سابق نفذه القطع
الشهر الماضي
ايضا وهو امر غير مسموح خلال قرنين كامل
من العمل النقابي وقد قرر الممرضون
الاضراب يومين اخرين الشهر المقبل ومثلهما
في مارس اذان المقبل
في بريطانيا ان نحو عشره الاف من العاملين
في مرافق الاسعاف
سيضربون لمده سته ايام اضافيه وفي شهر
فبراير ومارس المقبلين
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم ومناقشه هذا الموضوع وينضم الينا
من لندن
وزير الدوله البريطانيه السابقه ورئيسه
لجنه الدفاع في البرلمان البريطاني
والنائب عن حزب المحافظين كما ينضم الينا
من باريس
الحقيقي
ما الذي فجر كل هذه الازمات الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه في عدد يعني من الدول
الاوروبيه نتحدث عن عدد لا يساهم به من
الدول الاوروبيه البرتغال اسبانيا فرنسا
بريطانيا وغير ذلك
ياسر
يحدث في الامر لا يؤثر على دولتين واحده
لكنه يحصل في اوروبا بشكل عام اذا ما
نظرنا الى سنتين الماضي كان هنالك
حدثان مهمان كان لهما تاثير كبير على
الاقتصادات اولهما الكوفد الجائحه
وتاثيرها
الذي
طريقه تفاعل العالميه مع هذه الازمه
والامر الثاني كان هو الحرب في اوكرانيا
التي كان لها تاثير كبير على اسعار الغاز
واسعار الطاقه وايضا على اسعار المواد
الغذائيه ايضا لان الحبوب كما عرفنا مؤخرا
انها التي كانت هي مهمه جدا والتي كانت
تاتي من اوكرانيا لم تصل الى الاسواق
العالميه ونتيجه هذين الحادتين كان لهما
تاثير عميق على الاقتصادات ايضا بامكاننا
نظيف الب
والقرار قرار بريطانيا لمغادره الاتحاد
الاوروبي كلفنا ايضا الكثيره كلفنا حوالي
4% من اجمالي الناتج المحلي في كل عام
وعلينا ان ننظر الى هذا الامر بالتالي
مجموعه هذه العوامل الثلاثه وخاصه في
بريطانيا قد ادت الى الكثير من القطاعات
العامه لكي تقول انه بالرغم من التضخم
الذي وصل الى نسب غير مسبوقه هم يزالوا
يدعون الى المزيد من المال لان نحن نفهم
انهم يريدون المزيد من المعده داخل المال
غير موجوده غير متوفر بالتالي اوقات صعبه
اوكرانيا حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بالنسبه
لبريطانيا البريكسيد ان تضيف اليها اشياء
اخرى
شخص تركي سؤال نحن متفقون
صحيح ان الاسباب
متشابهه ومتماثله بالنسبه لكثير من بلدان
الاوروبيه هناك ايضا على اي حال
ازمات ماليه واقتصاديه واجتماعيه وهناك
ايضا ارتفاع
عدد من العوامل وكل هذه الاشكاليه حرب
اوكرانيا
والتضخم
والجائحه تفيد المتطرفين وخاصه اليمين
المتطرف في فرنسا وبدا اخرى مثل
ايطاليا
اليمين المتطرف في وصل الى الحكم
هذا نتيجه ايضا
لهذه الازمات وهذه الاشكاليات التي تاتي
في ظروف شديده التعقيد والتي بدات قبل حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا والحرب على اوكرانيا
لم تكن الا عامله تسريع لهذه الازمات
الموضوع وصول اليمين المتطرف الى الحكم في
عدد من هذه الدول لكن لو ركزنا على
بريطانيا
وهناك استطلاع للراي نشرته شركه ابسوس
يقول 57% من البريطانيين يحملون الحكومه
البريطانيه
المسؤوليه الاكبر عن او في اضراب الممرضين
وطبعا انت تعرف انه هذا اكبر اضراب
للممرضين في تاريخ بريطانيا خلال قرن ما
الذي يمكن ان تفعله
الحكومه البريطانيه في هذا الصدد لحلحله
هذا الوضع
السؤال في القطاعات الخاصه والاضرابات
حصلت لان
اجهزه الدفع المستقله هي التي تحدد كيفيه
تغيير الاجور فيما يتعلق بالقطاع النقل او
القطع الصحي همم وما يحدث انهم قاموا
باجرائه وتقديم توصياتهم قبل تاثير
الغزو اوكرانيا هنالك تضخم كبير في
بريطانيا وصل الى 11% بالتالي الكثير من
هذه الزيادات في الاجور كانت ضئيله جدا
مقارنه بمستوى التضخم لكن الحكومه ستجادل
انه التضخم الان يسيطر عليه نحن نجده طرقا
اخرى من اجل الحصول على احتياجاتنا طاقه
قويه من دول عده من ضمنها قطر بالتالي
نحتاج الى ان نقدمه تنازلتنا نعترف ان
الارتفاع عاد في الاجاريه يجب ان يتم
مراجعاته ولكن يجب القيام بها بشكل عادي
لكي لا نزيد من التضخم بالتالي زياده
الدين العام العامه ولكي يطابق الاحتياجات
من مختلف القطاعات العامه المختلفه
الى ما قاله توبيس الولود من موضوع
الرفع الزهيد او الزيادات الضيئيله جدا في
الاجور ايضا بالنسبه لفرنسا موضوع رفع
السن ال- ال- التقاعد همم الى اربع سنين
62 سنه الى 64 سنه الى اي مدى هذا عقد
الموضوع اكثر في في فرنسا
نعم 64 سنه
ينبغي ان لا ننسى انها خرجت من ازمه
السترات الصفراء في 2018
عدد كبير من الشعب الفرنسي والتضخم الذي
كان قد بدا وسياسه الرئيس
الذي لم
يساعد
الاكثر فقرا والعمال واليوم في في النهايه
ما هو مهم هو ان يتم
توفير واا اعاده النظر في سياسات العامه
ليست فرنسا التي قررت ولكن بروكسل
والاتحاد الاوروبي وكان الحكومه الفرنسيه
في بلدين في
وفي بروكسل همم هناك رئيس يضع
اصلاحا عنيفا يمكن ان نصفه بذلك يطالب
الناس من العمل لمده اطول
برواتب ليست
تتناسب ولا ليس فيها زياده حقيقيه وهذا
امر غير مسؤول الدين العام في فرنسا ليس
شيئا جديدا هناك ادوات يمكن ان نستخدمها
ولكن ليس لا يحدث ذلك
باحتجازي او التاثير على فئات ان هي
الاضعف من الموظفين والعمال الحرب في
اوكرانيا فرنسا
تحاول في تحولها في مجال الطاقه الى
الخروج من تبعيتها
للغاز همم الروسي
اه اي سيدنا
شركاء اخرين ولكن ذلك يتم على حساب الشعب
والفئات الهشه ونحن في
فتره ينبغي ان نذكر بذلك تاريخيا
اشتعال اسعار في اوروبا
والاضطرابات
الاجتماعيه نتيجه لمواقف
الجبهه الوطنيه واليابين المتطرف والناس
يستمعون الى جميع القرارات التي
تفرضوا من قبل بروكسل وهذا امر غير مقبول
ولم يعد مقبولا
ولذلك هؤلاء
المسؤولون مسؤولون عن الوضع الاقتصادي
للبلد ومسؤولون عما يحدث للاسف في اوروبا
هم ينبغي محاسبتهم في فرنسا هناك
تجنيد
ضد
التقاعد مع النقابات والاتحادات العمانيه
في دول اخرى في دول اوروبيه اخرى يعني سن
التقاعد 65 سنه في المانيا في بلجيكا في
اسبانيا في الدنمارك مش بس 65 67 سنه
يبدوا الامر بالنسبه لفرنسا مبالغا في
كمطالب حسب البعض
الا ترى ذلك
فيها بعيد عن ذلك فرنسا ليست بلجيكا وليست
اسبانيا وليست اوروبا فرنسا هي فرنسا
بتاريخ
ومسار اجتماعيه
والسيره ونضال ومكتسبات
هناك مليونان من الفرنسيين يعيشون دون
مستوى خط الفقر
وهم
يتحملون الازمه بالكامل بينما الرواتب لم
يتم
زيادتها ويريدون ان يفرضوا عليهم هذا
الاصلاح المتعلق في
التقاعد وهذا همم غير مقبول بعض البلدان
الاوروبيه سن التقاعد اعلى ولكن ليست فيها
نفس الظروف الاجتماعيه
ينبغي ان نتحدث عن هشاشه ظروف العمل في
نعم طيب شوبيس الويت في لندن يعني كلاكو
يعني انتم الاثنين متفقان على انه ايضا
حرب اوكرانيا الحرب الروسي على الكره
اوكرانيا اثرت على الاوضاع في الدول
الاوروبيه لكن الا تتحمل الحكومات
الاوروبيه الحكومه البريطانيه والحكومه
الفرنسيه
المسؤوليه عندما تقرر زياده انفاقها
العسكري عندما تقرر ارسال المال عندما
تقرر ارسال المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
بهذا الشكل الكبير وكل هذا على حساب
شعوبها واحتياجات شعوبها
يوافق
سالتي سؤالا مهما للغايه لانها بريطانيا
هي ربما مقارنه بالدول الاخرى قامت
بتبني هذه العولمه بالتالي سمحنا لانفسنا
ان نكون متواصلين مع العالم بسبب العلاقات
التجاريه بهذه وهذا ما نحن عليه لكن عندما
يكون هناك تعطيل العلاقات التجاريه وعندما
مثلا الدول لا يمكنها ان تجري صفقات
تجاريه مع بريطانيا ونحن نعتمد عندما
نعتمد على بضائع معينه تاتي من اماكن
وتوقف هذه البضاعه فان اقتصادنا يتاثر
بالتالي هنالك علاقه مباشره بين
اقتصاديتنا ورفاهيتنا وبين الوضع الامني
علينا ان لا ننسى ذلك والمثال الاوضح
هوكرانيا لو همم لما نعناع روسيا من
احتلالي اوكرانيا عن طريق الاستجابه
لطلباتي الرئيس
الى ننيت وقدمنا له الدعم قبل الاحتلال
قبل الغزو الروسي لربما كانت تبخر في ذلك
الوقت في بريطانيا 4% وليس 11% مثل ما
يحصل الان لاننا لكننا نعتمد بشكل كبير
على الغاز والنفط وعندما تعطلت هذه
الامدادات وايضا امتدادات الغذاء بالتالي
تعطل على العالم باكمله اعتقدوا ان هذه
جدليه قويه هو يجب ان ينظر الى امننا
العالمي الذي بدا يتدهور ليس فقط في
اوروبا لكن في الجنه شرق اسيا مثلا في
الشرق الاوسط ايضا ان عالمنا يصبح اكثر
هشاشه وهذا الامر سيؤثر على كل
الاقتصاديات ليس فقط على اقتصاد المملكه
المتحده
الوضع المعقد الذي يعيشه العالم اليوم
التهديدات الجديده تبرر كل هذا الانفاق
العسكري وهذه المساعدات لاوكرانيا طبعا
يتحدث عن فرنسا التي ذات فيها الانفاق
العسكري
باربعمائه مليار يورو خلال سبع سنوات يعني
من 2024 الى 2030 ست سنوات عفوا
جو جو جو انا اتفق معه صحيح ان هذه
التبعيه في مجال الطاقه لفرنسا وللعديد
البلدان الاوروبيه
لانها تسيء الى الاقتصاد
والشعوب
وفي الحقيقه
الامن
هذه البلدان لكن هناك
الحرب في اوكرانيا وهناك المساعدات التي
ينبغي تقديمها لاوكرانيا الحرب لها
تبعاته وهي فظيعه بالنسبه الاوكرانيين
وايضا بالنسبه للشعوب الاوروبيه ونرى ذلك
مع ازمه الطاقه
واسعار المواد الاوليه وكل هذا التضخم
المتزايد
اكوتي
هناك المساعده التي يتم تقديمها الى
اوكرانيا وفي اوقات الازمات حيث الناس
يتحملون في حياتهم اليوميه عبئ هذه الازمه
الاجتماعيه يجدون صعوبه وفي فهم
هذا الدعم في فرنسا
دبابات
خفيفه الى اوكرانيا طبعا ينبغي مساعدته
الاوكرانيين
واا ينبغي ان تنتهي الحرب وان نجد مسار
السلام اذن هذا
المساعدات تحدثت عن 400 مليار بالنسبه
لفرنسا لكن في النهايه
صناعه الاسلحه في فرنسا هي استثمار ايضا
وهو شيء يعود بالفائده وهذا محزن ولكن
الحرب
توفر المال وفي فرنسا
الاموال المجموعات الكبرى والشركات الكبرى
ونحن في ازمه همم تسجل ارباح تاريخيا
توتال
وتحسب بعشرات مئات مليارات
اليوروات ده هناك اموال
وهذا المال يمكن ان نجده في فرضي ضرائب
الفكره واضحه تماما نعم نعم
وهنا نتحدث في الاخير عن
هذه الاضرار يعني بالنظر الى كل هذه
الاضرار التي تتحمل همم تتحمل في نهايه
الشعوب الشعوب الدول الاوروبيه الا يمكن
ان يدفع هذا باتجاه ربما تبني
لازمه اوكرانيا بدل الحلول العسكريه
المكلفه جدا
والمستنزفه للمال الاوروبي
امين يا جنى
اعتقد ان روسيا متهيئه للعبه طويله اعتقد
يحرك بلده نحو حرب طويله كان هنالك اجتماع
اليوم
اوكرانيا
لتوفير انظمه ثقيله لم يمرر واعتقد ان قوت
النساء يشعر بالسعاده لم نقتسم بالقوه
الكافيه لمواجهتي المتنمر بوتن استغل هذا
الضعف
وهو محزن في حول مناقشتنا التي حصلت هذا
اليوم وهو اذا اين اين
سنطفي النار في اوكرانيا اعتقدوا انه
سيكون له تاثير عميق على الاقتصاديات
الاوروبيه ولذلك سبب تحديدا يجب ان قوم
بالمزيد من اجل دعم الشعب الاوكراني لكن
اصبحنا
متادرد الدين بشكل كبير وقوه سيتمتعه
هذا الصراع وتحويله الى صراعا جامده لان
قدره روسيا على
تحمل الصعوبات هي اكبر بكثير من قدره
اربعه شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكما توب يسالويد
من لندن وزير الدوله البريطانيه السابق
ورئيس لجنه الدفاع في البرلمان البريطاني
والنائب الان عن حزب المحافظين
كتبنا من باريس الناشط الحقوق الفرنسيه
والى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر لكم منى
[موسيقى]